all right so today's topic I had a
little incident recently where I was
traveling there's actually was a while
ago and while I was traveling I had a
guess stay with me or during my
experience someone I only kind of knew a
little bit not too well but I was like
you know what you won't stay with me I
would say it's fine
yep and me and this person mean this
lady had an incident so when I kind of
just play the video that I recorded
right after it happened and then me and
preach will react to me I am in LA right
now I'm doing stand-up comedy I'm doing
showcases so I'm trying to get on you
know saying and
during this process I was messaging
someone long-distance from another
country she's like how visit LA and I'm
like yeah host you for a couple days
I've got some days off during this
weekend you have a place to stay so just
fly yourself out and we'll hang out and
I'll host you and show you around town
it'll be fun right
I'm a great host and so this person
flies out I helped me get to my place
right we go out for food I feed them I
placed a I show them around Thomas we're
having a good time first night and if
guys don't know this about me I got
sleep apnea but I got like bad sleep
apnea you know I'll tell you guys how I
found out sleep apnea steady good nurse
she woke me up and she's like you're a
burr when you sleep we got a problem and
I was like yeah uh we got a problem
why the [ __ ] did you wake me up you're
my problem and she's like no happy when
you sleep you make a weird noise and I'm
like what noise and she said you make
the same noise in your sleep that I make
when I suck your dick
okay we got a problem I know I know it's
what laughing cuz this is sorry this is
not your [ __ ] face this is like
that's what she said and I was like [ __ ]
we got a problem
that's too gay
like sucking dick Aziz I could do that
my sleep I was like [ __ ] I do it this
is when I took the steep study so then I
go to doctor he's like yeah you sound
like you're sucking on multiple dicks so
I snore really loud and when I travel I
don't have my seat that machine so so
she couldn't sleep and the next day I
took off to Santa Monica we went out for
burgers we went out for food we went out
for checking out their different offense
we went out it was like it was like a
10-hour visit around the city but she
kept saying like oh I'm really [ __ ] up
I didn't get to sleep at all last night
you were too loud it was really bad for
me and I felt terrible because I like to
host people properly so that evening in
order to make her comfortable
I took my mattress I put it on the bed I
let her half the bein bed I slept base
much on the floor and I'm like you know
what just get some sleep I promise I'll
handle it tonight you're gonna sleep
well right that was my cold because in
my country the way we do it is that our
guests sleep better than we do we make
sure our guests are more comfortable
than we are that's how I host people so
she went to bed she woke up the next day
she said well that was great sleep how
what happened and I told her you know if
I had just in my pillows when in reality
what happened was I just didn't sleep
and by me not sleeping I didn't snore
therefore she had a good night's rest
that was my whole plan and then I did
some work in the morning I went to the
cafe I'm like you'll get some rest just
sleep up a little bit extra because I
know you didn't get any last night I'll
be at the cafe working 3-4 hours go by
she comes to meet me we go for lunch
could I have this cool spot I want to
take to where there's like really good
desserts like I'm going fallout to make
her see some [ __ ] when we get back is
about rollin p.m. and she just okay I
want to go downtown I wanna do more
stuff today and at this point I haven't
slept in like probably 36 hours my
body's feeling it I can't pull
all-nighters like I used to do someone
hey can I get like a four or five hour
nap and then I'll take you out for
dinner and I'll go do some other stuff
and she kind of seemed a little bummed
out but she suggested that she can go
see a friend and she asked me if that's
okay I was like yeah
in LA you don't see your friend a lot yo
go see your friend have a good time so
she goes sees her friend she comes back
and she's drunk she's really wasted she
starts saying passive-aggressive stuff
like uh yeah but you've come you're an
incomplete person but I really like you
when you know I don't think you're in
touch with your emotions but you seem
like really cool to be around and and I
don't feel really sexy right now but
give me your faces you like grandma
faces she started like like like like
licking you I see that what yeah that's
like I'm not even exaggerating details
okay so I was like oh and her breath was
like heavy with alcohol and cigarettes
all the guilt that I'm not feeling it
right now
she finally got taken aback by that but
I'm like yo it's cool we're gonna go out
we're gonna walk up to a restaurant
nearby we're gonna have some good food
and we'll just chill breaks I still want
to hurt have fun in town so we're
walking and we're singing a sketchy
neighborhood like a semi sketchy okay
walking and we walked by these two guys
and she screams East Coast he's closed I
don't like you know why are you being
heat back chill out don't be yelling at
strangers in the middle of the night
it's [ __ ] weird and you're gonna
start problems actually don't do him I'm
fine
then these guys walked by and one of the
guys says hey to her and she says hey
and he's like you look good like yeah
you kind of look good
[ __ ] she says like some weird insult
like to start some beef and I'm like you
need to chill don't start no beefs
because if you do that I'm gonna have to
fight these guys and I want to fight
nobody like you some people on the
street don't yell it would be actually
great if you wouldn't fight yeah if they
like you trying to start some [ __ ] it's
like yeah it's like I thought me and my
partner and I'm just gone there's like a
ghost space oh you just look at the guys
like nope
imagine if you got hit randomly that's
one thing but if you start bronze they
more focus smack the [ __ ] out of you and
I'm gonna be like you deserved it why
should I put my health on the line what
if these [ __ ] got a knife what if they
got a gun on the south part of the East
Coast would it be a knife is your
problem a gun [ __ ] but what if they
doesn't matter
in the reality like if that happens and
it's my life being put at risk because
you want it to be a drunk potato right
from I'm mad at this point and this way
and I told her down the street if we're
gonna keep yelling I'm gonna come back
to the house cuz I don't like this this
is wack it's like no you won't you know
I'm like yo don't test me she's like
you're not gonna go back to the house
and I was like yo listen if you do that
shouldn't get I promised I would she
said I will do it again and I was like
you know what I'm a man of my word I'm
never lied you girl I'm heading back
when you say some [ __ ] do it don't say
some [ __ ] that you're not gonna do
that's what I see a lot of people do in
their relationships they say things and
then renege on it so then your partner
recognized that not only are you a week
with your word but that if you aren't a
man of character they can defy you and
you'll stick around and that's something
where I set my boundaries very clearly
about myself and if you cross them then
I will punish you whether you guys
taking my some other situation or
whatever I'm never gonna hit you or
punish you that way but I will not allow
you to cross my barriers and think I'm
gonna just tolerate it nobody has that
right over me you do that [ __ ] again and
you will walk that's I was an IVA car
you do some dumb [ __ ] like that again
you can walk and then when that [ __ ]
happens or the person confirms to you
that that [ __ ] will happen that means
that your word she doesn't care about it
which you say reciprocate and in most
relationships like especially with women
early on there will be time so they will
test your boundaries they'll hit you in
little places they'll make little slight
comments and that's on you guys to
rectify that behavior right away to be
like I'm not gonna take that [ __ ] and if
you keep going I'm out I don't need any
kind of toxic behavior oh I always say
this about ladies cuz I don't dig man so
if ladies if men are having this kind of
behavior - then you should chin check
them on that poll real quick okay
anybody I just say this is about women
cuz that's who I date I never want
people to think that I think women are
trash meaning like that just that's a
white date so when I deal with problems
I'm speaking about women but if men are
doing that ladies take that as ancient
don't hey don't let nobody [ __ ]
talk to you like that who's that guy
girl nobody but I don't want to give
ladies advice to things that aren't
actually happening so ladies you'll tell
me if that happens to you okay
she chases me down the street I'm with a
couple blocks away and I guess she
thinks she'd done some training day
because she starts yelling you're gonna
do this to me and I'm walking away like
that white boy like Nando would shoot
you crazy just like that and I just kept
walking without moving back no
hesitation so I get back to my place I
walk in quiet now keep in mind this
place that I'm renting right now belongs
to a friend and she has roommates but
she's like even have my room it's cool
okay
and I felt grateful to her because she
saved me a lot of money by digging this
place I'm already grateful for this
great space that I'm staying in I walked
her to the room I start cleaning up
tacking up
she walks in makes a lot of noise noise
all the roommates then Watson to the
room he starts screaming now we sound
like a domestic couple I've been dating
for years when I've only known this girl
for a couple of weeks and she's making a
big scene and I'm only at one point I
was just like hey can you calm down
because I'm a guest and she says oh
you're gonna throw the fact that you're
hosting me in my face again because I'm
your guest app I'm like no no we're both
guests in this house this is not our
apartment can you can you chill like I
won't scream she's like you're not gonna
tell me what the [ __ ] to do
she starts packing her stuff she's going
crazy and I'm just like what is going on
right now cuz I've never in my entire
life it's all my dating experiences ever
been in a situation where I'm in a
shouting Mountain I don't I don't raise
my voice one thing people tell me they
don't even know what it sounds like when
I screamed it I always tried to keep
calm when I grew up in a household which
is a lot of yelling and a lot of
fighting I think I just kind of
inoculated myself from that I don't like
to engage that energy
that's what make something clear in this
I'm not downplaying my volume or making
it sound like I was being super rational
when I was because I know sometimes when
people tell stories that they were
involved in they make themselves always
seem like a good person the other person
is Romi I'm gonna play recorded for you
guys later
well you're gonna hear that I was super
quiet and she was super loud because in
that moment I just felt shame I wanted
everything to end and I didn't want to
draw any attention to us so she was
going the opposite direction
not friends but I know you okay and
we've been through a tea together yeah
some pretty [ __ ] up [ __ ] and Haiti
yeah in Haiti and I'm the one that's
gonna be like nah this ain't gonna go
like that to all this [ __ ] we went
through he won't be the one that's gonna
be super calming sheep and that's my
word cuz that we've been through [ __ ]
there you go so you got his word you
have my word and also [ __ ] I don't play
no games I got recording let's go
so she's berating me at this point she's
screaming at me it's not shouting much
it's basically just her shouting at me
and she's saying foul [ __ ] and actually
I recorded some of it because it was so
crazy at one point she said something
like for you to behave this way you're
gonna make me leave now
exact old dark I don't want your abusive
energy like this if you're gonna just
swing this whole time and then she gets
up in my face and she grabs my face like
this and I pushed her hand away and then
she hit me I said don't get abusive
right now cuz right now you tripping she
starts hitting me and it took everything
inside of me and I'm glad I broke cuz if
I was 21 I would have just socked her in
the face real quick okay so little
context when I was younger I got into a
lot of fights I was what got arrested a
few times for fighting people like
random that it really [ __ ] up teenage
years and and back then it didn't matter
if it was a man or a woman I just didn't
like being touched just cuz of my
childhood when people touch me
I was instant fight most like this and
I'm not gonna be like try that again
I'll just punch you in the face that's
how I used to be and nowadays I'm very
calm and not to fight in seven years and
I want to stay away from that but I know
if you grabbed me [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you sober yeah I don't know if
people admit this I'll tell you the
truth there is very few feelings better
they whooping a nigga's ass since you're
seven years sober pin but no the feeling
of never being OS that did something is
hurting I always quote that Tupac Wayne
revenge is like the sweetest joy next to
getting [ __ ] and I'm telling you when
you knock somebody out
it feels bad that's relevant and all
that rush like is but I also saw the
dangers of that with people like getting
paralyzed so I'm like I'm never fighting
again [ __ ] up and I don't want that
I'll do it and even in this situation
where this girl's being abusive she's
been physical me as a man in another
country the last thing I want to do is
put my hands
any type of weight not because I don't
think I want equality but because I know
that if somebody walks in or hears the
screaming plus me having my hands on her
they're gonna say domestic abuse I could
go to jail very easy you can get very
bad yeah touching a white woman you know
are they American cops no thank you
so I'm just cops they got a history yeah
so I didn't want to risk it so I kept I
remember just thinking how much [ __ ]
it is that I had to endure that and I
was so pissed in that moment it was
probably the only time when I started
like yo now you're getting abusive keep
your hands off and and me if I get to
that point where I'm speaking that
sternly
it's that where I'm starting to Teeter
over the edge and so that's just the
point but thankfully she sided my eyes
that I was dead ass serious and she
backed off she started hitting me and
I'm like do you realize that you're
being physically abusive right now that
because you don't like some of the
things that I've said and I've asked you
to leave my space you are being
physically abusive and she kept hitting
me I'm like this is part of the reasons
why I made some of those videos about
women's abuse because I can tell for
them even when we say it's abuse they
don't register it they see nothing wrong
with it
and so this girl's going through that
night because she's emotionally
frustrate and I can understand that she
is because she can't get the words and
the feelings that she wants out to me I
won't touch on that point that is
something that I really feel is true and
a lot of the dating experiences I've had
women I've been with have been
physically abusive not in ways that
threaten my life but my waist I invaded
my physical privacy even when I said no
and they never saw anything wrong with
it which is why I made that video of
women hitting men and just how like
non-solid like yeah I hit man sometimes
I get frustrated hit and they don't
realize that that kind of stuff that
kind of Liberty that they feel when
things get a little bit more heat it
goes a lot further and so that's why I
always caution people against allowing
that behavior to happen just because
women aren't as dangerous as men when
they're being physically abusive does
not mean that we should condone that
kind of abuse and I always reiterate
this because I've been on the front end
of it from women and I've never hit them
back when I've dated them but I've seen
so many situations where I'm like I
should have slapped the [ __ ] out of you
but because you have a vagina I'm not
going to and that's wrong I'm not saying
that I shouldn't let it be wrong if I
did I'm saying I all want to because I
would be seen as being in the wrong by
the world and there's legal
ramifications that I don't want to deal
with
and in those times he starts yelling
stuff she said yeah your dad he must
have ran out on you for you to behave
this way not knowing that my dad died of
cancer when I was 21 right no drunk or
no it doesn't matter for any behavior
that is done by drunk people is good no
because it's drunk I'm not saying nah
[ __ ] that [ __ ] that's it drunk or not MA
you're gonna go my dad and my whole
family [ __ ] [ __ ] you I get what you
saying [ __ ] people get to that stage
where they're saying all this nonsense I
tune them out and I've already cut them
out of my life mentally you know we do
you're dead to me Bob a week so that's
why only me you can't hurt me so I don't
let anybody have control over my catch
on fire I wouldn't piss on you to put
you out see you're here vent your
vengeful me I'm just like you're dead to
me and I shut down and we'll talk about
your vengeful okay I'm vengeful and you
saying you're dead to me
if the person is burning the process the
growth of the dying yeah but to me you
go piss on her I'm not gonna piss on I'm
not gonna watch even she stops he'll pop
my mom which I know for a lot of [ __ ]
watching right now they blade you talk
about my mom I slapped the [ __ ] out of
you I didn't do nothing and she just
kept going and going and going and going
in and at one point she said yeah you
didn't even want to spend time with me
today you went to bed not knowing that
the reason I didn't spend time with her
is because I wanted her to feel so
comfortable I decided to stay up so she
wouldn't hear my snoring just so she
could sleep comfortably and I explained
that to her in that moment that's
quietly and she disregarded it and this
is what I mean when I say sometimes
people they don't understand how to
receive love in a way that's different
than the ones that they're used to
receiving they're not understand how to
receive affection and the way that's not
how they're used to so okay I won't talk
to on that point and that was something
I really think about is that people
receive affection one way yeah and if
you don't show them affection in the way
they're used to therefore you are not
affectionate your defection like you're
defective in some type of way and that's
not the reality we all have different
ways we show love some people are gifted
some people like compliments some people
talk a lot so I mean we just sense
some people is this quality time where
they're really focused on it for me it's
more affection based I'm very like
physically affectionate you know all
those little things I also give people
my time when I can't offer it and I make
gestures every now and then right so
that's the waste I show my fiction but
because it's not the way that she
understood love or she understood
affection she just thought something was
wrong with me you dig what I'm saying
and she didn't realize that you know me
wanted to get away from her and me
telling her to leave my apartment and
get out it was not me hating her this is
just me loving myself you think I'm
saying you've got a lot of stuff exactly
I have to be protective my own
boundaries in myself and in order for me
to be in a relationship with someone and
if you're going to cross that boundary I
don't want you gone because I hate you I
just want you gone because I love myself
you know I'm saying is I'm not mad at
her Ivan no the will to this person even
though she said some foul things even
though she was physically you still have
no ill will I love myself too much to
allow that kind of person to be in my
life for longer do you dig what I'm
saying so I would just tell people out
there if you're dating just don't don't
be one-sided and narrow-minded and how
you receive affection see how the other
person does it and if the way they show
affection is not for you then stop being
that person but don't tell them that
they're defective don't try to make them
feel terrible for not showing love the
way that you're used to but to me it
means this and that and that yeah but
that's to you to you you need to learn
to know each other and that's what it is
yeah but that's not me yeah like people
would actually shut the [ __ ] up it's a
different person you're talking about
anyways you said what you said so let's
just keep on going that's pretty much
the end of it you said you had a
recording no you can't okay yeah you
can't just skip that [ __ ] like that [ __ ]
didn't happen I even have that new
pocket we waiting for that she the
recording of how calm you were it's
pretty much just in French most of it
but subtitles
[Music]
mmm don't worry I was just like okay
well what could I have done
d0 say like there's nothing I could have
done so what am I gonna yell at her then
because he's a thing when when you're an
arguable somebody the worst thing you
could do is add field to the argument by
are yelling back at the person why
because especially with ladies for my
igniting experiences they just want you
to say something tell the worst thing
you could do the thing I would piss them
off the most and what is actually the
best thing to do is to not say anything
why because not only does it piss them
off more but after a while it stops
feeding the flame that they need in
order to keep this argument coin love
and hate are the same side of the coin
on the spectrum hate is closer to love
in differences all the way out there try
it
anytime to argue with the girl just
being different it'll drive them [ __ ]
mad now that's not what I was doing in
this case I was just not engaging
because I didn't want to feel that way
but for her I knew was driving her crazy
you see how happy she was when I said a
few words and just reacted because I was
no longer being indifferent for her it
was a victory even though she didn't
understand what I said she coming up ah
you see I win that was basically a
response I don't know who the [ __ ] you
are
okay but yeah call me call me and tell
me how abba is not my friend so I know
cuz we understood that you told her that
we're not friends yeah but let me just
give context so she said oh you free
treat you like best friends but what
people don't realize is because we have
such an intense work relationship we try
not to hang out after hours we don't
really call each other frivolously to be
like what something good like it's not a
friendship like that we have a real
working relationship that takes so much
out of us that we need separation after
work so I wouldn't call us friends per
se but we respect each other it's just
one yeah well that and you get mad like
I consulted him you want to call me and
tell me how he said that to you like it
was some kind of secret like it's a
mother I'm the first person he said that
- I was like muffled I'm not your friend
either the third grade she uh uh Jeremy
Jeremy is not your Jeremy said he's not
your friend he's not my friend
this [ __ ] here is not my friend
don't get it twisted crazy yeah like you
told me she's not your friend I should
call them and tell them that who are you
captain Mattel captain no you probably
said like but I did like come on now
come on now calm down come on now but
she realized it she wanted to say like
love is that what they love you like me
you love me at this point if you don't
know no I have my earphones on and I'm
just trying to - she was screaming right
beside me and so I'm like I don't want
to hear this is too much I just didn't
want in case I was just not saying
anything so I explained to her why she
had a point you had a point
she can't dispute that and and this is
what she said - the fact that I sit up
on it
[ __ ] hole from anyway so am i I'm
sorry
see how she's trying to make herself
single a good person for us she says I
could never be with somebody who snores
like you with just right you know
whatever middle condition but if you
feel that way that's okay
blues after she said all this stuff
about my dad being gone how I wasn't
raised by okay okay okay okay
[Music]
and I didn't do it
bro listen I found that fudge da man
really like she's drunk but that is not
an excuse it's actually never an excuse
ever not in any other case not in that
case it's not an excuse
if you shitty when you're drunk your
shitty person all you're dealing with
some deep bums that you haven't really
addressed address them but don't blame
the alcohol for your irresponsibility I
didn't have to suffer your physical
abuse because you're drunk okay Jimmy if
I never let a man beat a woman just
because he had a few beers right we call
him a deadbeat well then you're also in
that category for what you did
you know and look I'm not mad this
person I have no ill will
I've moved on already mentally I'm good
but you know sometimes I make these
videos about women and their behaviors
and people are like oh a but you're
going too far you're misogynistic no
just because I see it and look I'm not a
poor judge of character this is the
first time I'm 28 I've never had a
shouting match you know the reason why
she felt so comfortable hitting me in
that situation was because the whole
time she's ever been alive she's never
heard women shouldn't hit men she's
never heard it women should you know
take account of believe you're that
woman should you responsible for that
yeah we should come out with a new
Gillette ad where women take
responsibility for their [ __ ] because
believe it or not you guys you guys
start half of all marital abuse you were
maybe not as physically damaging but you
are just as likely as men to be abusive
in relationships as [ __ ] up in that in
the lesbian world it's [ __ ] up I'm not
doing about it and you know it's even
crazier 2/3 of women who are bullied or
bullied by other women in the workplace
so you guys are engaging an extremely
toxic behavior but I never hear anybody
talk about toxic femininity we
attributable eing to men as if we're the
only ones and we say men man can do
better no people can do better
hmm the only difference is men
constantly have to hear about how
they're evil and how they're doing bad
[ __ ] but win or women gonna get called
out for all their false rape accusations
what are they gonna get called out for
the fact that they get to be physically
abusive without any repercussions are
all mobic she hit me this whole time if
I call the cops he's not doing a day of
jail time a day I mean
well how'd I put my hands on her that
would it be to me that was fun how do
you put yeah you hushed her down it
would be dead you know it's just like
I'd be right down to doing like a
fundraiser like yeah if you're my [ __ ]
Ava why do you think I recorded this
conversation it wasn't cuz I could plate
later it's so that I had a safety net in
case she said anything shady because I
don't know what you might do the next
day she might feel tremendous amount of
shame and anger she's like I'm gonna
[ __ ] his life up and call the police in
in a jaded moment I'm like I'm keeping
the recording so people think you did it
but she could have she could have and it
would have [ __ ] me up so you know
people say all you guys are very
misogynistic it's not that it's that
nobody's holding you guys accountable
and I have to deal with the
repercussions because I date actively
and I just see some of this wild [ __ ]
that y'all be doing I know it I've had
fear false rape accusations that came
out to be ridiculous afterwards and I'm
like why why should I have to suffer
that and that nobody talks about it but
every day I got to hear about how
masculine is toxic from where I'm
standing the most amount of damage
that's been done to me has been done by
femininity right but we don't have a
term for that
so you asking keep saying oh man or
toxic this and that and feel free I
don't mind but you're not the ones who
date women right and women do need to
hear it you're not allowed to be
physically abusive you're not they're
not it's as bad as man so I'd want to
share my personal story I don't like
putting out my [ __ ] out there normally
but it's not mentioned you know nobody
knows who this girl is
there's a man I haven't told priest
haven't told nobody and I never will
because I respect people's privacy like
that I'll just bring this story because
I think it speaks to a bigger problem
but I know you watching
[Music]